hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
when the name Olympus is brought up in
the context of Corporations what comes
to mind is probably the image of a quiet
Japanese company that makes cameras but
what about a decades-long running fraud
well that's the stuff of banks oil
companies and large corporations not the
unassuming Olympus but in reality they
did commit the largest fraud in Japanese
history much like the previous scandals
we've discussed on Cold Fusion this
cautionary tale is an unwelcome light
shown upon the internal struggles within
large corporations the people who run
them and the ongoing pursuit of profit
and power it's also the story about how
one man chose to do the right thing and
uncovered a multi-billion dollar crime
this is the tale of the Olympus fraud
scandal
[Music]
TV
while Olympus is mostly known for their
cameras by the general public the
Olympus Corporation is heavily in the
business of Precision Optics and imaging
technology established in 1919 Olympus
was initially known as tikachi ho
focusing on the production of
microscopes and thermometers the spirit
of innovation was embedded in the
company's DNA from the beginning
in 1936 Olympus introduced the Olympus
one its first camera and this would
establish the company's footing in
photography however the company's
Innovation Ambitions were not just
limited to Optics although it had begun
in scientific equipment it wasn't until
the 1950s that Olympus took its first
steps into the lucrative field of
medical equipment it all started with
the gastro camera the predecessor to the
modern endoscope this move
revolutionized the field of medicine and
helped establish Olympus as a leading
player in the industry
after officially changing its name to
Olympus the company began releasing one
Innovative advancement after another
from launching the Revolutionary pen
camera Series in 1959 which introduced
the world to the half-size 35 millimeter
film format all the way to introducing
the world's first digital microscope in
2001. Olympus was continually redefining
boundaries the company's foray into
digital photography in the late 1990s
and early 2000s highlighted its
adaptability to changing market trends
by the dawn of the 21st century Olympus
had grown into a multi-faceted
corporation with a healthy business and
science Imaging and medical sectors they
were a trusted name known for their
reliability Innovation and commitment to
helping improve people's lives this is
why uncovering a significant financial
fraud Scandal was so unexpected
this was a company that had Survived the
Great Kanto earthquake of 1923 World War
II numerous economic downturns Olympus
wasn't just a corporation it was an
institution a testament to Japanese
resilience and Innovation and this made
the Scandal all the more shocking
it wasn't just about numbers it was a
breach of trust a use of Weasley
cover-up tactics and a blow to a symbol
of Japanese corporate success here's how
it all began
[Music]
inside the high-rise Olympus Office
Buildings a culture of corporate deceit
had long been in operation
now it all started with a desire
in the 1980s a lot of Japanese companies
were struggling to make money from their
exports and this was thanks to their
strong currency the Japanese Yen Olympus
Executives wanted the company to appear
stable and prosperous and if it took a
few shortcuts to get there so be it
Olympus Executives began artificially
inflating the company's books distorting
the reality of its Financial Health
[Music]
who was the Olympus president from 1984
to 1993 spoke to the Nikkei industrial
newspaper in 1986 and here he said
something interesting he revealed that
Olympus had to resort to financial
engineering to make ends meet in other
words the company invested in financial
derivatives and other risky Ventures to
try and make some cash
and fortunately for Olympus the Tokyo
economic bubble burst in the early 1990s
so their financial engineering plan
didn't work out so well
in 1991 Olympus had lost 84 million
dollars on their Investments after the
boom times had ended Financial results
from October 1999 revealed that they had
lost 123 million dollars by playing in
interest rate and currency swap Market
to give you an idea of how desperate the
company ended up being they lost a
further 22 million dollars in a Ponzi
scheme over time the losses kept piling
up reaching in excess of one billion
dollars but they remained hidden and off
the books this was a bad situation
Olympus needed a way to make the problem
go away and fast the plan that they came
up with was absurd it was as follows
Olympus would purposely buy up a bunch
of companies at inflated prices they
would then use the excess funds within
their accounting to cover up the string
of bad investment these excess funds
from the fake prices they paid were
written down as income for example their
accounting would state that they bought
a company for 10 million dollars but in
reality they would pay 1 million the
other 9 million be used up to cover some
bad bets that they made earlier
with this absurd plan they went on a
shopping spree and bought more than 100
companies in sectors as far as pet care
and DVD production obviously Pet Care
was at the Forefront of olympus's Core
Business
another tactic was to overstate advisory
fees Olympus paid exorbitant advisory
fees to fictitious companies or entities
these fees were recorded as legitimate
expenses but were also used to hide
losses but sometimes these companies
were real for example Olympus acquired
the gyrus group a British medical
equipment company on top of the two
billion sale price Olympus paid an
unusually high advisory fee of 687
million for the purchase
not long after this Japan had a change
in accounting regulations panicking
Olympus had to book its assets to fair
market value so to hide the fraud it
resorted to creating off-balance sheet
entities to conceal the losses one such
entity was axis a dubious investment
firm run by Akio nakawaga a central
figure in the Scandal instead of
reporting its impaired assets Olympus
funneled them through axes the fake firm
and repurchased them at grossly inflated
prices again using the overpriced
Acquisitions to cover actual losses but
in all of this chaos it's difficult to
cover Your Tracks completely and the
deceptive techniques did not go
unnoticed the company's Auditors KPMG
began raising concerns about the unusual
accounting practices particularly the
inflated advisory fees but their
concerns fell on deaf ears instead of
coming clean Olympus Executives did
exactly the opposite they switched
Auditors replacing KPMG with Ernst young
thinking that they had dodged a bullet
Olympus Executives had no idea that the
Scandal was already unraveling all it
needed was a little push
enter Michael Woodford
[Music]
they say they're going to sue you yeah
well if they would like to come to
London in the high court and go through
this then I'd be more than delighted I'd
relish it you know please serve the
papers on me tomorrow please do it you
know I would love that Michael
Christopher Woodford british-born
businessman had worked for Olympus since
the 1980s he was a stickler for the
rules he went from salesman to manager
and by 2001 was overseeing a large
portion of olympus's European dealings
but in 2008 Woodford couldn't help but
raise an eyebrow at a handful of
mysterious Acquisitions the acquisition
of the previously mentioned gyrus group
should have fallen under his watch but
instead it was strangely handled by
Tokyo officials more specifically the
CEO and president and chair of Olympus
tiyoshi kikakawa a very unusual
occurrence it was becoming clear that
something wasn't quite right
deeply troubled by the irregularities
Woodford was on the verge of handing in
his resignation but before he could he
was showered with assurances that
everything was in order and suspiciously
he was promoted to head of European
operations at Olympus he was also
appointed a seat on the main Olympus
board of directors
they were just hoping that Woodford
would take the promotion and shut up of
course he didn't
in early 2011 a German colleague of
Woodford raised concerns over
information that they'd seen in a
Japanese business magazine called Factor
the article also found several past
Acquisitions as suspicious explicitly
stated was the 697 million dollar
advisory fee spent on that gyrus group
deal the same deal that Michael was
supposed to work on only to be
mysteriously handled by the CEO
mirroring the events of 2008 the claims
were brushed off by superfighters but
this time Woodford would push for more
explanation the story was showing up in
Publications outside of Japan and as
woodford's position in the company grew
so did his responsibility and any
potential Fallout from a scandal of the
size coming to light
he penned letters to olympus's CEO
kikukawa demanding a response and
threatening to resign once again
and yet once again the company's
response was to not address the issues
but instead to promote Woodford he
became CEO and president replacing
kikakawa who would remain the company's
CEO
but the strange corporate Behavior
didn't end there within six months
Woodford was handed the CEO position
while kikawa would remain chairman of
the board Woodford kept being promoted
but that's not what he wanted he just
wanted to know the truth of what was
going on at the circus of a company
the move to make Woodford CEO was not a
popular one everyone was confused some
were just thinking that he had been
given the top position so kikawa could
have an easy leader to control from the
sidelines this was true but the
reasonings for this move were more
sinister
unfortunately for kikakawa Woodford was
far from obedient using his new power
Woodford set out to uncover all the
wrong doings he had suspected in doing
so he recovered records of transactions
showing hundreds of millions of dollars
being transferred to Offshore accounts
when he brought the new information to
the board he was met with vitriol this
time there was nowhere for Woodford to
go but down he was abruptly fired from
the CEO position and kikikawa was
reinstated the dismissal of Michael
ignited a flurry of speculations and
debates about the extent of the
company's involvement in fraud it also
indicated that something was deeply
amiss within the corporate corridors of
Olympus fearing for his safety Michael
Woodford fled Japan to England here he
would immediately begin cooperating with
investigators
there's a complete lack of confidence in
the financial markets at the integrity
and the governance which exist at
Olympus and for very good reason until
we deal with this issue the company is
in a very bad and unstable position and
we can deal with it we just need those
directors who've been responsible for
these transactions to be held to account
and there's increasing pressures upon
them to do so normally if you're
acquiring a company professional advice
would be between one and two percent
Olympus paid 35 35 nearly 700 million
dollars which is almost two years
profits of the entire Corporation to
unknown parties in the Cayman Islands
olympus's efforts to keep the Scandal
Under Wraps were undone the moment
Michael Woodford was promoted
his persistent digging is what led to
his abrupt dismissal and the dismissal
is what Drew attention from Regulators
worldwide
the cat was out of the bag and on
November 8 2011 Olympus for the first
time admitted to its fraudulent
accounting practices
they acknowledged that they had used
funds to cover up losses on investment
the blame was placed squarely on former
CEO kikawa auditor hideo Yamada an
Executive Vice President Hisashi Mori
all of them would like to face charges
the confession from Olympus however came
too late the Scandal had already
snowballed into one of the biggest and
longest lived Financial frauds in
Japanese history 19 officials resigned
and faced a lawsuit for the massive
accounting scam all board members were
implicated in the Scandal and resigned
at an emergency shareholder meeting in
2012. this resulted in a sharp drop in
olympus's shares they fell by about 75
to 80 percent in response to the
disaster criminal investigations
commenced across Japan the UK and the US
sweeping changes had to be made at
Olympus
2 700 jobs were cut about 40 percent of
its 30 manufacturing plants were closed
down by 2015.
the stock price did improve as a result
and gradually as the Scandal faded from
public memory the stock today has grown
to multiple times of its mid-scandal
lows
[Music]
in response to the mounting pressure
from regulatory bodies Olympus was
forced to establish an independent
committee
the six-member committee led by the
former Supreme Court Judge had the task
of unraveling the tangled web of Deceit
despite the mounting evidence of fraud
Olympus managed to avoid being delisted
from the Tokyo Stock Exchange it did so
by backfiling five years worth of
corrected financial statements and
overdue first half results just hours
before the set deadline a slap on the
wrist when compared to the magnitude of
financial fraud but it was by no means
over
as the Scandal continued to be
investigated it brought about a massive
shake-up in olympus's top management
kikukawa the board chairman who had
hand-picked Woodford for his roles found
himself assuming the CEO position once
again but it was promptly replaced
kikawa was destined for something far
less glamorous in a rare instance and
large corporate fraud there was Justice
in February of 2012 Tokyo police
arrested seven individuals including
kikakawa Hisashi Mori and hydro Yamada
a year later the district court handed
down a fine of 7 million US Dollars
against the Olympus Corporation this was
for breaching the financial instruments
and exchange act moreover kikawa Yamada
and Mori were handed suspended sentences
ranging from four to five years
in 2015 the Tokyo District Court
sentenced to further three Securities
Brokers of Olympus
in 2017 six former Olympus Executives
were ordered by the Tokyo Court to pay
over half a billion dollars in Damages
in 2019 a shareholder derivative lawsuit
by the Tokyo District Court fined three
officials a record-breaking
435 million dollars as for our
whistleblower he was rewarded handsomely
for his efforts he received 10 million
pounds from Olympus for defamation and
wrongful dismissal
it was revealed that Olympus had
concealed 1.5 billion US dollars in
losses since the late 1980s but when all
was said and done investigators estimate
that more than 4.9 billion dollars was
missing from the books Olympus once the
epitome of corporate success was now the
poster child for corporate fraud it sent
shockwaves throughout the Japanese
corporate landscape and four years after
the Olympus Scandal broke the Toshiba
Corporation would be caught inflating
seven years of earnings to the tune of
1.2 billion US dollars I guess Japanese
business wasn't as clean as most of us
thought foreign
the Olympus Scandal shows us the dangers
of wanting to appear profitable at all
costs it led to a call for more
transparency stricter regulations and
better checks and balances in Japan and
Beyond whistleblower Michael woodford's
actions inspired others to pursue truth
and Justice even at personal cost the
Scandal highlighted the struggle between
greed and integrity complacency and
vigilance corruption and Justice it
remains a reminder that the truth and
justice will prevail over fraud when you
lie about the numbers you can only get
away with it for so long in the end of
it all a catastrophic failure awaits
as a side note I'm glad to see that
there was some justice in the Years
following the fraud some high up
officials got absolutely blasted by the
Japanese justice system so it sends a
clear message to others don't do this
so that is the story of the Olympus
fraud
suggesting quick housekeeping I know I
rarely talk about it but the second
music channel was almost at 20 000
subscribers so if you like what you hear
I'll leave a link in the description
okay so thanks for watching my name is
and you have been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next episode cheers guys have a good
one
with the lights
[Music]
cold fusion it's new thinking